my pharrell dishes on working with
Justin Timberlake and Ariana Grande
they're epic people it was a day date
for the 44 year old new dad to triplets
and his wife Helen at the premiere of
Despicable Me 3 on Saturday I really
must have a word with you on behalf of
your twin brother drew why twin brother
hey brother please do that are you
rolling with today my wife
how are the triplets all good um it's
good great
but the triplets aren't the only thing
keeping Pharrell busy these days what's
coming up for you Justin Timberlake and
new ariana grande really that's gonna be
[Music]
their epic people so I think if anything
the music's just a derivative of like
who they are I mean you know who Justin
is and you know what he's done all these
years and what he's continuing to do in
Ariana you just saw how how bright her
star shines at this moment you know I'm
not a little bit completely focused my
mother's office
yes she's thinking about other people so
she's just in a really good place
[Music]
you